there's so many different things to
investigate why China well so my
investigations on China started way back
in 20 it's re 2008 and it was actually
unintentional to be honest I had
stumbled across some pretty strange
occurrences there were acts of you know
physical attacks taking place in one of
the big Chinese communities and over the
course of a few years I uncovered what
was what's now called and very well
known as the United Front work
department basically how the Chinese
regime extends its suppression and arms
into foreign communities working with
things like tongs these fraternal
organizations that basically run
Chinatown
you know organized crime you name it got
it so that's kind that's kind of what
prompted you so as you got in at what
point did you say I'm gonna go much
deeper than I am right now well it was a
step-by-step thing so when I first got
into this beat I mean it was stuff I'd
never heard of you know people were
telling me oh you know that guy's a spy
this guy's a spying on I'm and I'm in
Chinatown I'm seeing people physically
attacking people I'm seeing these large
groups come out with signs and people
are getting death threats people are
coming up to me and they're telling you
know Chinese people they're telling me
oh they told me they can you know
threaten my family they told me they can
make me disappear and you know I mean
it's bizarre III never encountered
anything like this I had no idea how to
understand it and so for me the
investigation was more I had a lot of
questions and I wanted to figure out
what was going on and try to get to the
bottom of it over the course of time of
course after I uncovered the initial
pieces of it yes that these individuals
were of course being rallied up by the
Chinese consulate the Chinese consulate
general at the time panca you we
actually had some stories showing that
he was meeting with the individuals
encouraging them and so on
found out over time that you know this
is a bigger picture than what I thought
initially and over time I uncovered
what's now pretty well known which is
the Chinese regimes whole system of
unconventional warfare culture warfare
business warfare cyber warfare you name
it that's been their maintenance so
that's what you've come to conclusion
with now how often have you been to
China yourself
never I am I'm proudly blacklisted as is
epic times overall we do have offices in
Hong Kong and Taiwan though but mainland
China we've been blacklisted almost from
the get-go when you say blacklist says
what does what does a blacklisted mean
because people have told me hey some of
the stuff you talked about could
potentially get you blacklisted what is
what is blacklisted
well blacklisted for some media means of
course you have no visa they don't tell
you why you can't go there you're never
allowed to go you know the research
there or reporting there for us
blacklisted started I think in 2000 soon
after we launched at Pok times Chinese
officials or Chinese police knocked on
the door of you know some of our Chinese
staff who were in China arrested the
entire office or editors spent 10 years
in prison and they tortured him one of
your editors from epoch down spent 10
years in prison and tortured them yep
[Music]